okay so let's now get to the next piece
of this North Korea thing I told you a
couple of weeks ago that Donald Trump is
increasingly taking foreign policy
advice from Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson making this really the Fox News
presidency I mean Donald Trump's daily
agenda is often set by watching Fox
News's Morning Show Fox and Friends
they'll talk about something 20 minutes
later Trump tweets about it and it's on
the agenda for the day or for a week if
Trump has not much going on that week
Trump regularly talks to Fox News
propagandists Sean Hannity in the
evenings and gets Hannity's advice
before Hannity puts them to bed and now
Tucker Carlson has been added to the mix
it is truly the Fox News presidency now
I will say it just so happens that some
of Tucker Carlson's influence on Trump
might be better than what Trump would be
getting from people formerly in his
administration if even for the wrong
reason so like as an example Tucker
Carlson seems to be against going into
Iran that's good I'm also against going
into Iran we don't want Donald Trump
going into Iran we then learned that
this weekend when Donald Trump stepped
in to North Korea for the first time by
any sitting president to shake hands
with Kim jong-un on North Korean soil
that it was Tucker Carlson rather than
Donald Trump's actual national security
advisor John Bolton who was with Donald
Trump on this trip Bolton instead was in
Mongolia not exactly the center of the
action over the weekend while Donald
Trump was in North Korea with Tucker
Carlson and of course concurrent with
this Tucker Carlson is running
propaganda for Donald Trump's
relationship with Kim jong-un saying
that to lead a country you're going to
end up killing people in some way shape
or form
check out this cartoonish video tucker
carlson calling in to fox news
tucker just one thing that you know that
that's the type of thing that does make
some people nervous though he recently
president Trump recently made a comment
about having a certain type of good
chemistry with Kim jong-un and that may
be true but when you're talking about
someone who has been responsible for so
many human rights abuses
does he run a risk with that kind of
language of a
coming off to kim jeong-hoon like he's
pandering to him to an extent or be
upsetting the American public that that
elected a president that they want to
stand firm and be tough on those human
rights violations and stand firm on
American principles which exists in in
virtually complete contrast to how the
North Korean regime is run yeah I mean
there's no defending the North Korean
regime which is a monstrous regime it's
the last really Stalinist regime in the
world it's a disgusting place obviously
so there's no defending it on the other
hand you know you've got to be honest
about what it means to to lead a country
it means killing people not on the scale
that North Koreans do but a lot of
countries commit atrocities including a
number that were closely allied with so
you know I'm not a relativist or
anything but it's important to be honest
about that now this may come as a shock
to some people but Tucker Carlson is
right to some degree even about the
killing stuff in a very particular way
now I want to be really clear American
presidents aren't killing people in the
way that North Korean leaders are
killing people but what Tucker Carlson
is right about and it does not get
discussed enough is that through the
decisions of foreign policy that
American presidents make people die as a
consequence and the question is how many
and for what reason that being said this
is a completely ridiculous way to defend
Donald Trump who is being totally
bamboozled and conned by Kim jong-un
period and that's really the problem
here as I've pointed out so understand
what's going on as Tucker Carlson is
becoming Trump sort of de facto national
security adviser over john bolton
traveling with him giving him advice
about Iran and North Korea we have the
choice of outrageous war hawk war monger
John Bolton or white nationalist Tucker
Carlson which is better I don't actually
know I mean I truly don't know at least
recently on foreign policy tucker does
seem to be sort of providing Donald
Trump with a less bad point of view
which is stunning to even be saying it's
actually possible that the world would
be better off with Tucker off Fox News
where he spreads probable a terrible
propaganda and as a slightly less war
hungry alternative to John Bolton his
National Security Adviser I mean that's
hilarious to say it's also tragic to say
that that might be the case and in the
meantime remember that the coziness
between this administration and Fox News
continues to be completely disgusting
it's effectively state media at least
for the time being and you only have to
look back at how Fox covered North Korea
under Obama versus how Fox covers North
Korea under Trump to understand the
totally propagandistic nature of this
look at this would you as president meet
with the leaders of a country like North
Korea Obama extraordinarily said I'd
meet with him senator Obama made his
intentions crystal clear on the campaign
trail I will meet not just with our
friends with our President Obama likes
talking to dictators he would meet with
some of these madmen without any
preconditions you know I'm gonna reach
out to these crazy people around the
world and try to get things yeah I think
that's a mistake
Obama is bowing and scraping before
dictators what is Team Obama doing
establishing formal contacts with these
people a remarkable turnaround in
relations between two historic
adversaries the commander-in-chief's
leadership is now leading to a major
foreign policy breakthrough another
stunning Donald Trump breakthrough so I
could keep showing you more of the
gushing by Fox over Trump on North Korea
but you probably understand it by now so
these are these are really strange
dystopian times that we're living in and
I guess in a sense Tucker Carlson is a
bigger and bigger part of those strange
times let me know what you think are we
in a way better off with Tucker Carlson
giving Trump foreign policy ideas rather
than his completely war hungry true
national security adviser John Bolton
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the show
is on twitter at david pakman show let
me know what you think if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by skill share and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to skills share when you
click the link underneath this video
skill share is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
do classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video